my secret is my secret is my secret is  hi my secret is i'm a hybristophile i'm  sexually attracted to like  stuff like murderers and like serial  killers like fictional or like real life  and like for me it's like the violence  gets me off  and uh  i'm pretty much on the sadistic side  i'm just weird like that and a lot of  it's expressed through my art  okay so  one time i had this ex that  cheated on me with some random girl i  found out who the girl was started  talking to her  and i started dating her as well as the  talking to my ex still and i found out  that she had a boyfriend so i ended up  dating him as well so i end up dating  all three of them at the same time and  they didn't even know  [Music]